Karlis what are you doing I'm trying to
figure out how I can automate all my
lamps and devices without manually
configuring each one oh I have a
solution for you just build some digital
trains what's served a digital train is
like a digital version of your physical
devices let me show you how to build one
on Google cloud platform that sounds
awesome let's get started
[Music]
the solution we built today looks like
this the blue boxes are managed products
which we can use directly the only
places where we need to write our custom
code are the two yellow boxes which are
cloud functions that links are your tea
core and pops up with fire sir
so all the infrastructure will be
managed and we are just writing some
custom glue to fit the pieces together
yes let me show you the code for this
project we need to have IOT core setup
you can find it in the console I have
created a registry which is a grouping
of IOT devices under it I have gateway
devices where our simulated IOT device
will be talking to the gateway device as
you can see here I have my simulated
device called lamp one bounded to the
Gateway you can find the device by
clicking on devices as well once the lab
is connected then it will send events to
IOT core every second an event update
the event will be sent from IOT core to
pops up and pops up triggers the event
to cloud functions I also have another
function applying changes from the user
to the device let's look at the code I
use the device ID as my reference for
changes reading changes from fire store
and eventually updating the device with
the latest info now let's look at the
firebase site I made a collection of
devices with different states like on
and off I also added the mode field for
brightness of each lamp so now in cloud
shall I run my code
see what's happening in fire sir I have
added my lamps so you can see the index
is increasing while each one is sending
their data to IOT core and fire store
let's change the mode of the lamp
assuming you have an app and change it
through that but I'll change it mahir
manually to soft the lab mode
immediately changes to soft this change
is real-time and quickly handled by fire
store for you this is how you can be
your own digital to in solution try the
lamps well it's worked yes indeed try
out IOT core and firebase for yourself
and the link below and don't forget to
subscribe for more great Google cloud
platform content as simple as that
not even a compile error no not even a
compiler
[Music]